okay wait so how many so is okay how do
you devise women like let's let's just
so there's a junior college woman who's
after a junior junior college women
there's
um we have seven levels of qualification
I teach men the seven levels of
qualification so the first level is do
not qualify all right you don't qualify
that's level number one all right uh the
next level hold on for a second
she a bust the Pillsbury biscuit can all
right she's she ain't she don't qualify
all right so I'm gonna go down to my
Seven Levels here I gotta get it right
here there it is right there all right
so uh level ones do not qualify qualify
number two is service provider
like she can give me something I don't
want to keep her around for long
so she can give me some there's
something I want from her I gotta find
out how I can get that sometimes it
could be money sometimes it could be
attention wait she wants it from you or
you want you I want something from her
you want money from her no no I want her
access to her oh okay and then you have
to figure out what she wants what do you
want okay okay money attention money
energy attention on time like what is it
so then she's providing the service but
I ain't keeping around for long okay uh
number three is gonna be practice
okay practice for your wife no practice
for six all right she just I meant like
like that's okay never mind yeah yeah
right oh she practicing for my wife yeah
so yeah not you not you in particular
you're not gonna get remarried no but
like but for others it's like practice
for that yeah she practiced like like
you'll be like okay let me just work on
a couple of things with her yeah yeah
but she is that's just gonna be it I
can't practice dating her but I can
practice just just being in bed with her
she practice a lot of girls will
practice
they get treated like breakfast what I'm
telling you most guys do instinctively
but women don't notice but I'm just
clearing people in uh the fourth level
was gonna be she's a part of your con
your concubine or your Harem okay which
people will call rotation okay
yes
so you're she's in my rotation she's a
concubine
but a concubine can be gifted and taken
care of that's what a concubine inhero
means she could be like like a a top
tier yeah she's on my side she's still a
concubine she's never getting married no
no your place know your place yes don't
come don't come to my house
yours you know what I mean but I might
be paying you know I might be hooking
you up you may you might buy her dinner
might buy her dinner we might go on a
trip she might get a repay oh she's
making her rent pay concubines are
supported oh okay but but you you're
still concubine you ain't gonna you're
not moving in all right the next level
is a regular this is a friends with
benefit right so she's a regular Oh I
thought the last one was what the
concubine I thought that was the like
what's the difference between a
concubine a concubine I might not have
access to all the time I just have her
on the side NBA players typically are a
sports celebrity might have a concubine
in each City he's not with her all the
time but he has her just for himself
when he needs and so the regular is like
one step regular is like I see you every
week I see you two times a week right
that's a regular but a concubine
typically could be like a woman will say
she lives in Toronto and she'd be like
I'm dating some player who plays for the
Lakers
well that can't be possible how often
does that player in Toronto very little
right but in her mind she's dating that
player that's a concubine
she don't see that guy a lot but a
regular is somebody I see and we're just
messing around how often do you see a
concubine how many times a month oh you
could there's no there's no level okay
sometimes the concubine has never seen
or scene she's just taking off the
market
so this is how people have to study with
these terms you never see her you have
to see her once to make her a concubine
I can not necessarily so let me tell you
how kings have used concubines like this
is a real education for a lot of people
people will use these terms and they
don't know what they mean a a king or
somebody who's Noble or who has access
to women typically will take women off
the market so they're not defiled by
poor men right so that maybe she might
have a later use maybe she might be a
surrogate maybe I might want to
impregnate her right because I look at
her she has value but I'm gonna take her
off the market because I'm valuable
enough to do so but that don't mean I
have to see her all the time
right right you're beautiful
sometimes but she's you think so but
she's getting supported oh okay so it's
concubine the support a lot of times men
don't they use this term concubine as a
[ __ ] those are two different things
talking about in a horror are two
different things Christmas the practice
or is the practice Yeah practice is a
[ __ ] yeah so a regular a regular a
regular might be a girl that I'm just
hooking up with and hey I see you every
week every two weeks whatever that is
she's a regular a pretender Tinder is a
woman who thinks she's white material
okay but she ain't okay as a woman I
know my worth and you might give her
some attention this is the born-again
Virgin they're born again version
Pretender single mother Pretender
single mothers are Pretender that's like
the yeah single mothers are pretending
the panel the other day was one of the I
I know I know the archetype yeah you
know the archetype so she'll have men
she'll have babies by other men one or
two or three maybe more and she'll be
like I'm a wife and I'm like waiting for
my husband [ __ ] yeah that she's a
pretender never take her seriously okay
and the contender is gonna be that girl
like I could marry her final round draft
pick she's a top tier draft pick I want
to marry her I'm gonna pull her off the
market we gonna be together Contender
but that is a rare
most everybody you're meeting is either
a concubine Harem she's a hooker [ __ ]
or she's a pretender or she don't
qualify
that's the reality of it so people that
when men see you men don't have to see
you for very long to put you in these
categories ah so if you're wondering why
you're not getting wifed up probably
look how you present yourself ah
so it's been one of those I wanted to
see I wanted to see the other one so
they're more uh well no that's just the
symbol of it most of these are just like
the banners I put up for my show
like interesting ones on
um no this are there any other terms I
need to learn
um so this is the junior college these
are the levels of the junior college no
this is a level for all women okay
18 to 26 maybe extended to 28. oh
yeah
and then oh here I got something to show
you well I don't know if it will pop up
on your screen I won't show it on your
screen so here's your age groups right
here how I've oh wait a minute so put
them up right here so here it is right
here so 18 uh 16 to 20 in some places
16s whatever it's young and dumb all
right young and dumb uh when when you're
young and dumb you get the chances to
make mistakes right we all get to make
mistakes but of course the women's time
clock is a little bit shorter don't be
out here doing stupid stuff until you're
25 you're gonna fumble the bag all right
uh 21 to 24 this is your Mrs degree
right you should be searching and in
general based on the rules of nature you
should be searching for the man you're
going to marry meaning your behavior has
to start reflecting marriage if that's
your intention now just because you can
Botox and implant yourself and put bbls
and go out here and ride the Carousel
and move to another city acting like you
wasn't hole in the last City uh go get a
degree and all that [ __ ] you could do
all that [ __ ] but that's all modern
conveniences right I can microwave my
food every day but that don't mean
that's healthy right the clock is still
talking about the biology
yeah yeah the walls lots of tickets yeah
okay so that's that's going to be what
you should be doing between 21 and 24.
so I'm at last call yeah yeah so last
call 25 to 28 that's when what you're
doing is this this is it you miss the
window of the Prime select men now the
men you're getting at last call
yeah all right you can do something with
them okay you can do something so it'll
be lower but it's gonna be you yeah you
ain't ain't you know what I mean like
they already done wife up the wife of
boards right but now you about to be
like you better put it out there okay uh
what is gonna be oh after 29 29 and 36
that's Hail Mary time oh okay because
it's like it's like the yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah I better uh the clock's running out
three two one half court yeah half court
because you know what's happening now is
you missed out on the guys who were
willing to get married when they were
young and dumb right when men didn't
have no idea what the hell was going on
right so now men have smartened up at by
30 and 35.
they're not going to fall for the okie
doke and you're waiting for the next the
only available men are going to be men
that weren't marriageable
and uh men who escaped or men who got
divorced and had other family so a woman
in her mid-30s
is probably going to get a guy who's
actually been in a long-term
relationship and or divorced and bro you
already kind of Tainted you can't get
tricked so that's what that next level
is and then 37 to 34. where did all the
good men go when they say in your 20s
yes yes that's where they back there
yeah or they were
ah yeah that's another conversation that
people don't want to have yeah so so the
reality is where did all the good men go
uh they was back there when you're they
were back there
16 to 28. 45 is the new 25. so when they
get past you know that 40 they're in
their mid-40s yeah they were like they
still walk around here they'll dress
like they're younger you know they'll
get implants or a boo they'll do some
[ __ ] and they'll be out out there at the
club talking about 45s I knew 20. it's
the older women that get the boob job
right now that I think about it it's
like putting new rims on an old vehicle
cool oh like why would you do that
like look at these nice shiny rims on
this old ass I'm a long-term thinker I'm
like you got it you're not gonna be 80
with those Ends
by the way you need to redo those every
10 years which is a cost
maybe they're going to still have them
in I've seen two there's people walking
around with them at ADL and here's the
thing
here's the thing
um you got to redo them every 10 years
and typically women who get married and
they get breast implants after they've
had kids they get divorced but then they
don't get the redo so I've been with
women who got uh busted up uh boob jobs
and one sagging down worse than the
other is a disaster all right so
and then after that game over all right
game over 53 50 50. it's really 50. game
over game you ain't about to pull nobody
you ain't but now they might give you
hope I'll find me okay you live in the
whole strategy now you could get one but
it's game over and then they'll always
say well I I know someone that did
exactly but it's like I know someone
that won the loss exactly I know
somebody that met uh her husband on
match.com her third husband well yeah
well is that gonna happen to everybody
no so they're they're you know living on
the prayer at that particular point but
uh I know people you know they get
disgusted at what I'm saying but it's
true no I mean I could let me let me see
this yeah you just worried about you on
your last call last call you got a
couple years left
so you better you better smarten up yeah
Hail Mary time well when I was
she buzzer beat her time you want to go
back to the buzzer like uh six misses
degree Mrs degree so you're preparing
yourself for that you these are women
that go to college right yeah yeah I did
go to college but here's what here's
what women in college age basically used
to do in the past so my mom told me to
get your Mrs degree like that's what she
told me so you're you're women when
you're in college men and women when
you're in college the people that you're
surrounded by are always in your age
group yeah right and that like 80 90 of
the people you associate with are in
your age group once you get out of
college it it's not like that anymore
right the only way you find that is at a
nightclub right everywhere else the men
are either older or super young it goes
right that so your pickings get Slimmer
just just leaving the college campus
your best point is to get with people
and attach them you know what I'll tell
you where I fumbled okay yeah I fumbled
it back yeah I'll tell you why at my
first college it was like
they called it it was I transferred
because because of sports okay super
easy to transfer but I did all the time
I coached Sports so college sports so I
know you were like I'm gonna go to this
school and ball out yeah I didn't like
my coach at my first school so I left
yeah it's kind of a dumb reason but I
was thinking I was like at that school
it was like
it was like the the ratio was off but it
was better for the girls
I was better oh I see so they had they
had more pickings yeah no like the like
girl like it was 60 meant 40 oh that's
rare and it was like all the degrees
were really good it was like engineering
Pharmacy
you should have paid from there and then
I transferred and I was humbled quick
because you went to the new school and
the new school it was like 70 women or
65 it was it was I was like I was like
oh wow so it was like at the first
school like yeah you should have stayed
there yet yeah yeah I think that's what
you're trying to do get married yeah
yeah are you trying to get married yeah
man that's a bad time for women your age
what to get married what do you mean
it's tougher no no as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible